peu la neige est astucieuse vous
descendez les champs elysées dans la
grisaille et vlan vous êtes en savoir
claire pu les pentes la vitesse oui mais
pour faire du ski
il faut être plus souple lui au moins il
a l'air d'un sportif d'un vrai elle elle
est comédienne pour passer en souplesse
de la scène à la piste fait de la
gymnastique
rien qu'un peu tous les jours et ce
sportif ils lui parlent un langage de
sportifs marché mais oui marché avec de
longues foulées pour la souplesse le
souffle
rien n'est meilleur il n'y a que les
premiers patikul oui ils passent par le
bitume de paris le chemin pour des
sports d'hiver réussis
la prochaine fois il faudra mettre des
souliers plan comme dirait molière le
chemin est long du projet à la chose
les escaliers quelle aubaine si vous
habitez au 6e sans ascenseur vous
deviendrez championne mais encore
faut-il les gravir ces escaliers talons
en dehors pointe bien à plat pour les
muscles du mollet pour des jambes sans
défaillance on ne fait pas mieux ah ils
se méritent les joies de la neige
[Musique]
la providence prend parfois la
silhouette reposant d'un vieil autobus
s'asseoir et la plateforme alors pour
apprendre à absorber les chocs
il a su la convaincre mais il a des
lettres de noblesse c'est écrit sur son
visage georges ima est professeur
d'éducation physique
il est même chargé de la préparation
physique de l'équipe de france de ski de
fond le ski ça le connaît
et le hasard fait bien les choses
[Musique]
l'ascenseur n'aurait-elle rien retenu et
les escaliers alors
[Musique]
e
est-ce larmes de la vengeance
[Musique]
enfin des chaussures de sportive
mais au diable la facilité le laçage du
soulier voyons pour le ski encore un
éducatif à portée de la main enfin pas
tant que ça les jeunes ou bien raide une
épine dorsale élastique
ça vaut bien ce nouvel effort
[Musique]
et songez marguerite qu en frottant
votre parquet vous le ferez briller bien
sûr mais en même temps quelle souplesse
promise à vos articulations vous le
ramasserez tout seul votre gant et vous
en éviterez des mésaventures
[Musique]
pour l' équilibre maintenant
esquissant équilibre il vaut mieux
niveau inchangé
[Musique]
au début on n'est pas très à son aise
mais après après c'est drôle c'est un
jeu nommé bongo marc bury cassant vous
aurez bien gagner un voyage dans la
neige sans accident c'est en courbatures
les courbatures on en reparlera demain
[Musique]